if you were to travel in the world if
eating is the thing that gets you the
parasites
what's a good advice for eating
in strange parts of the world mongolia
india china is there something you could
say by way of advice i think daniel
would say make sure your food is cooked
right but that's so boring yeah it's
unfortunate and he would agree with you
um because you know many vegetables are
delicious salads even are delicious not
cooked but they can have parasites in
them meats fish people like to have
uncooked fish
so if you want to be really safe and
boring just make sure everything is
cooked
now we have a case this week on twit
of a young man who went
i forgot where he went but he stayed in
a hotel i think he oh oaxaca mexico
stayed in a hotel
and he said to dan he came back with
diarrhea and fever
and he said i don't know where i stayed
in the hotel i just ate hotel food lots
of vegetables and fruits and
probably they weren't washed with clean
water you know he got something from
that
the bottom line is most of these
infections with parasites can be
diagnosed and you can be treated and
you'll be fine
so
if you really want to
experience the cuisine i don't think you
should worry about it
you